comes to collecting art it doesn't
always have to be framed joining us now
is Cameron Mandel with Rock Island
Auction Company who is holding their
accessories and arms auction this
weekend here in Las Vegas so first off
welcome to the show thanks for having me
you brought some great things here uh a
rock Auction Company who are you guys so
we're Rock Island Auction Company we're
located in Rock Island Illinois we were
founded in 1993 and we've grown to
become the world's number one auction
house for firearms and antique
arms and you've brought some items here
today what do you have here with us
today and also why is this stuff
becoming so popular when it comes to
auctions okay so first I'll touch on the
so you'll you'll see a print on both
sides of our table here these are both
photographs by LA Huffman he was a
notable 1880s photographer in the
Montana area so you'll see here you have
cattle themed and then a horse themed he
worked primarily with the a western
lifestyle taking photos and then later
on in life turned them into prints is
what you see here and you really capture
the Western lifestyle when you see these
photos you need the actual these are
actual photos that he took correct whoa
correct and he brought some you brought
some knives here as well there's a
couple antique bowies here on this one
you have a very nice Longhorn guard with
a horse and alligator decoration on the
back also some Pearl accents there the
attention to detail on these items here
on this table are incredible absolutely
absolutely the thing that is jumping out
to me is is the shotgun we have here
tell me more about this so this is a
Winchester Model 1895 and it's a
beautiful one at that you'll see on on
the side there it says Zane gray Zane
gray was a very famous author worked
notably in the western genre over 100
movies television shows
were based off of his novels and short
stories so how old is this gun this gun
is probably early 1900s we were talking
about 1883 in the yellow Stones prequels
this is the gun they were using on the
show could have been could have been but
on this one you'll see the engraving the
Golden Lace the relief card stock
it's a beautiful piece it is it's a
piece of art something like this how
much do you think this is going to go
for at the auction so the low end
estimate on that gun was four hundred
thousand dollars four hundred thousand
dollars that's a house yes whoa okay
four hundred thousand dollars and then
the sword here that you see the last
item on the table is a 1860 staff and
field sword it's a presentation to
Colonel Nelson a miles
of the 61st New York volunteer can you
hold that the sword up so everything can
see a little bit better I would ask to
hold them but I would get in trouble I
want to hold all this stuff here so if
you take a look you'll see the acid
etching the detail too here on the
actual blade itself correct correct and
then the gun this is a probably silly
question but is this can someone use
this gun does it still work it still
works it still functions most of the
time collectors with a gun of that
quality it's a safe Queen yeah
something you're holding on to it's an
investment piece that's art you know
that's going to stay in the safe be
proudly displayed on a wall in a gun
room so yeah most likely can we
appreciate you and all this stuff you
guys have a booth at the Cowboy
Christmas this week so you can see all
the stuff on display and then the big
auction is coming up auctions next year
real quick what's the website for people
Rock islandauction.com and also the
phone number is
1-800-238-8022 beautiful thank you for
joining us